as we quickly approach the end of 2020
many organizations are planning ahead
for next year
unlv has now partnered with the las
vegas global economic alliance to host
outlook 21
and bianca holman is live in our
newsroom with some insight hi bianca
the purpose of outlook 21 provides data
and insight on how companies and groups
can conduct business here in the las
vegas valley lvgea and unlv
teamed up to share information on what
they expect next year
locally nationally and globally on the
national level keynote speaker
christopher thornberg of beacon
economics
highlighted that consumer spending is
bouncing back better than what was
expected during the earlier months of
the pandemic
thornburg says the residential housing
industry is also looking strong
and it's a seller's market local expert
stephen miller shared
the next that next year's outlook for
our local economy
really depends heavily on people
gathering together like tourism and
entertainment
they're following the national uh uh
downturn that is the recession where
we're currently experiencing because of
copen 19
is affecting our visitor volume gross
gaming revenue hotel motel occupancy and
employment
here in in southern nevada for 2020 but
in 2021 we see
robust recovery
to that
now miller and thornburg they disagreed
when it came to another stimulus check
thornburg said that more time is
actually
needed to allow for the first one to
really pan out because
it many people put it in the bank
however miller
believes that since southern nevada is
basically ground zero for the pandemic
and has high unemployment many people
here would benefit
from another second stimulus check now
both experts agree that a vaccine will
help hospitality
and recreation industries because it'll
help them recover
because more people will feel
comfortable in large groups
reporting bianca holman 8 news now